نذهب الان الى السودان ودي المك مسلسل
سوداني ينضم لقائمه الجدل درامي في
المنطقه والحملات متواصله لايقاف الاعمال
منذ اليوم الاول في رمضان الشيخ رفاعي
شخصيه امام المسجد التي يؤديها الممثل
الكبير صلاح احمد هي محور الجدل الدائر
والانتقاد الرئيسي انها تتعمد الاساءه
لرجل الدين والحطم من شانه الضغط الرهيب
لمنع العمل عبر وسائل التواصل تسبب في
اعتذار المنتج عبر حسابي عن بث الحلقه
التاسعه دون توضيح الاسباب وبينما احتفى
كثيرون بقرار وقف العمل عبر اخرون عن ان
الشخصيه موجوده بالفعل في المجتمع
السوداني وتجسد شخصيه رجل دين فاسد لا
يعني استهداف جميع رجال الدين ويبدو ان
الجدل افاد المسلسل حيث حسدت حلقاته
الاولى معدلات مشاهده قياسيه وصلت الى
عشره ملايين مشاهده عبر القنوات الفضائيه
ويوتيوب
ما شاء الله تبارك الله حلويات
واحد اتنين تلاته اربعه
التي يحبها
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
على كلا ينضم الينا من الخرطوم الممثل
احمد صلاح اهلا بك احمد معانا شكرا على
تواجدك معنا في مساء العربي
ربما تكون المره الاولى التي تناقش فيها
الدراما السودانيه شخصيه رجل دين فاسد الم
تتردد اولا قبل اداء هذه الشخصيه في
قبولها
ابدا انا في الحقيقه انا قبلت المسلسل ككل
وليس شخصيه شيخ الرفاعي المسلسل بشكل عام
هو جيد ويناقش عديد من القضايا وعديد من
الخطوط في المسلسل يعني وشخصيه رجل الدين
في المسلسل اللي هو خط واحد من الخطوط
يعني بالتالي المسلسل ككل هو جيد والشخصيه
انه وجدت ان شخصيه قبل كده
واشتغلتها
طيب انا كمان عندي سؤال اليوم بخصوص
المسلسل
السؤال بيقول انه ابراز حب شيخ الرفاعي
لحلويات وبواسطه في اكثر من مشهد هل اليوم
في اشاره واضحه لاحدى الشخصيات الدينيه
المعروفه في السودان لديكم
ابدا
ما في اي اشاره لانه كتير صار في مشهد
عادي زيه مشهد
والله كله يفسر على هواه لكن نحن
ادينا مشهد عادي
لاي مشهد عادي يعني
ممكن كان هذا غير البسط تكون اي اكله
ثانيه يعني طيب أحمد طيب هناك تساؤلات لم
تبث حلقه الامس من مسلسل وادي الملك ما
فتح باب التساؤلات هل هناك اي سلطه او جهه
له لها دور في غياب هذه الحلقه صراحه
لا لا صراحه ابدا والله ما في اي جهه
واوقفت المسلسل ولا في اي جهه
حاولت ان توقف هذا المسلسل لكن كان في بعض
المشاكل الفنيه تمت معالجتك فيها في بعض
الضغوط في بعض الممارسات اللي حاولت انها
توقف المسلسل لكن نحن كنا حريصين انه
مسلسل يتواصل يعني كان في بعض المشاكل
الفنيه والتمت معالجتها واليوم نزلت
الحلقه نزلت اليوم بس
اجوبتك انا صلاح انا انا صلاح احمد انا
صلاح
من نادي مرات في اسم العائله كمان يعني
هذا نوع من النداء عنا هذا اختلاف ثقافات
في كمان نحن متفقين
بس نحن كمان بالعاده